you got in this famous accident terrible
accident and you were really uh you
didn't really you were really in bad
shape what the doctor told you no my
lawyer told me this ben morelli he said
our two biggest accidents in the world
was yours and princess diana's that was
walmart at the time walmart was the
third biggest corporation in the
universe
apple mobile mobile exxon apple and
walmart
now it's the fourth because of amazon
mm-hmm but that's why i'm out there on
the turnpike looking for amazon truck
man
you're trying to get hit by an amazon
driver i'm a beach chair and i just wake
up
so let me picture this you're sitting on
the side of the highway in a beach chair
you got your champagne
on amazon i'm paying for life
i'm gonna be in it
i'm gonna be here if i survive it i'm
gonna be in it
if i
a billionaire okay so and then uh
they your doctor i know you went right
to your lawyer but i tried to go to your
medical condition first and then your
legal condition i love how i say so
you're and you're like forget what the
doctor said
but when you got traumatic brain injury
uh oh
that's uh oh when you mess with
somebody's mind yeah so when i came back
i didn't even know how to eat i mean i
didn't no i didn't they had to teach me
how to eat yeah i remember all of that
like it was yesterday i'll never forget
it i had to walk i had to learn how to
sit down i had to learn how to do a lot
of things i was really bad really bad
did you think you would uh perform again
no i was afraid i was scared i remember
being home
in my wheelchair watching the 40th
anniversary crying 40th university of
snl very afraid and crying especially
with alec and tina gave that speech
about me
i just broke down i broke down
i remember
before the 40th we were talking about
what we were going to wear me and my
wife the lawyers we were talking about
what we were going to wear or not didn't
even home then he came back the next day
and said we're not going my wife woke up
at four o'clock and wanted to say y'all
gonna do what no you're not all they
need to do is see tracy morgan with his
pretty wife waving smiling is ain't
nothing wrong with him oh i see they you
your lawyer didn't want you to look like
you were too healthy i was bad he didn't
want me to be there period [ __ ]
walmart he didn't want me there like
that right you don't need nobody need to
see you like this right so
he said to me you want to go via
satellite i said no i don't want to be a
part of it then since i can't be there
no yeah swim black so then you end up
hosting my daughter was only 10 months
so she was just slow down to walk right
but she was scared of me when i first
came home i stayed in the bed for two
weeks i don't even remember that i
stayed in the bed for two weeks and then
my daughter would come to me because she
was scared of the wheelchair yeah and
that really hurt me that really hurt me
and whoa
she learned how to walk at 14 months and
when i seen her take a few steps i got
out the wheelchair my wife screaming no
no no and i took my first two steps
mm-hmm so me and my daughter learned how
to walk together wow that was my baby
and she's my best co-star ever she's all
in the last so jesus through the whole
season my best co-star ever
how when you how do you get back on
stage after something like that how do
you host saturn out live i remember when
i was when i first went back on stage
after the accident i was hosting
saturday night live and we were at
rehearsals
and then that night i decided let's go
to the cellar and my boy was like what
so let's go to the cellar let's go to
the cellar
and i grab the mic
i grabbed the mic
i remember
and it felt so good just to be welcome
back
it really did
and that day
i didn't think i was ever gonna touch
the microphone again
i did you had real doubt that people
i didn't think i was gonna walk again
i didn't think i was ever gonna walk
again
and i did
and i just fought
i fought to come out the coma i see my
daughter in a coma say daddy come back
she was only 10 months old and i fought
and i came out the coma then i just
wanted to be better
i wanted to be better in my life as a
better person
a better human being to others
that's all i wanted to be i wanted i
know he spared my life for a reason
spent my life for a reason so now i get
back to those who are less fortunate
i give out food
i just gave out like a month ago we just
gave out what
a thousand turkeys with the fixings and
i'm partnered with uh food banks of
america and now amazon is on board and
i'm giving out a thousand dollars to
five families and forty thousand
to any organization
and that's what i'm doing
december 16th
i'll be doing that and that's my mission
i'd rather be a good man than a funny
man any day i don't give a [ __ ] about
that now when it comes to being a good
person i'm building my house conan and i
don't build my house on a bridge because
life is just a bridge i'm building my
house on the other side of the bridge so
when i enter this kingdom i got
somewhere to live and my door is always
open to you because you're my brother in
comedy you're my comrade because with me
and you together out there we know how
to do it we do it together i'm not doing
this [ __ ] by myself and i know that i
know whenever i came on your show i
wasn't going to be by myself i know once
i get into a thing you went right with
me and it turned out to be beautiful it
didn't matter even when there wasn't no
audience when we did it at my house and
i'm in front of the shark tank me you
did beautiful do you know how to be
funny with me i don't think it's about
celebrities either i think it's just
about other people that you know how to
do it so
if i'm and you're the same way if
wherever i am if i'm
uh if i'm in the bottom of a coal mine
and i bump into somebody who's got that
thing
i just want to be funny with them
[Applause]
and we trapped in there i'm gonna turn
my light helmet on my own my light click
and he's gonna be crying i'm so late we
getting you we in here we stuck we
getting you
you're not no we're gonna do comedy down
there no i'm getting him pregnant
so wait if you're if you're a wait if
you're you're trapped at the bottom of a
mine
and you're trapped and you're trapped
you're gonna get the other guy pregnant
there's no way to get out oh he's
done he's done he's daniel why did you
go there there ain't no women in here we
were in the bottom of a mine
that's where it's going to stay at the
bottom of that mine whatever happens in
the trap mine stays i thought we had a
really inspirational thing going you
were in
you were in tears just a few minutes ago
and now you're getting a guy pregnant at
the bottom of a mind yes that's how
quick it happens
we're trapped in the mind you done
i was crying one minute